* Lockere Gitarrenklänge,
entfernter Gesang *
Eine junge Frau demonstriert
zusammen mit anderen Tieraktivisten
vor einem Schweinestall.
Die Tränen
schiessen ihr in die Augen.
Was hat sie erlebt?
Warum ist sie so berührt?
# ... the silence of the violence.
Davon handelt diese Geschichte.
# ... without you we're defenceless.
Anja S. steht ständig unter Strom.
Sie hat einen anstrengenden Job, in
der Freizeit ist sie Tieraktivistin.
Manchmal streift sie durch den Wald,
sucht nach Entspannung.
V.a. dann, wenn sie sich
über andere Menschen geärgert hat.
* Rhythmische Trommelmusik *
Ich kann nicht nachvollziehen,
warum Leute teils nicht sehen,
was ich sehe.
Oder warum empathische Menschen,
die auch kenne,
bei diesem Thema
einfach die Augen verschliessen
und nicht weiter
als bis hierhin denken.
Auf dem Weg zwischen Wald und Wohnung
kommt die junge Tierschützerin
an einem Bauernhof vorbei.
Dort sind Kälber
in Plastikboxen eingesperrt.
Sie sind leer.
Hier ist ein Kalb.
Die Tiere
sehen nicht unglücklich aus.
Ja, aber wie glücklich ist man,
wenn man das ganze Leben
in so einer Box verbringt?
Muss man Blut sehen um zu denken,
dass es einem Tier schlecht geht?
Würde man einen Hund so halten -
dazu noch an der Sonne -
würden alle schreien.
Anja S. kennt den Bauern schon lange.
Sie findet ihn nett
und plaudert manchmal mit ihm.
Die Aktivistin stört sich daran, dass
er Kälber von der Mutterkuh trennt.
Sie weiss,
der Bauer hat keine andere Wahl,
aber diskutieren
will sie trotzdem mit ihm.
Seine Frau sagt,
er sei leider nicht da.
Ich habe mit ihr noch nicht viel
gesprochen, eher mit ihrem Mann.
Ich sehe sie oft
mit ihren Kindern draussen spielen.
Und jedes Mal frage ich mich,
wie sie sich fühlen würde,
wenn man ihr
die Kinder wegnehmen würde.
Also wie bei den Kühen?
Ja, ich denke es jedes Mal,
wenn ich sie sehe.
Aber es ist eine liebe Frau
und sie ist immer nett zu mir.
Anja S. bereitet sich
seit Monaten darauf vor,
zusammen mit anderen Tierschützern
eine Aktion auf einem Bauernhof
durchzuführen.
Das ganze Land soll davon erfahren.
Das hat mir letztes Jahr
meine Mutter geschenkt.
Tiere wollen Rechte, genau wie wir!
Tiere wollen Freiheit,
genau wie wir!
Braucht es Überwindung,
das Megafon zu benutzen?
Ja, früher war ich
extrem schüchtern.
Ich hätte nie ...
Eine Präsentation vor der Klasse
zu halten, war immer sehr schlimm.
Plötzlich geht man
mit 20 Personen in den McDonald's.
Plötzlich redet man in ein Megafon
weil man weiss,
dass man die Leute aufklären muss.
Ich bin nicht mehr nervös.
Der Plan: Es soll ein Stall besetzt
werden. Welcher, das ist noch geheim.
Der betroffene Bauer
darf keinen Verdacht schöpfen.
Wir werden ihn nicht vorinformieren,
sonst könnte er
noch viel umstellen und verändern.
Es soll eine Störung des Alltags
sein um zu zeigen, was passiert.
Freuen Sie sich auf den Tag
oder haben Sie Angst?
Ich freue mich, weil so was in
der Schweiz noch nie passiert ist.
Ich freue mich,
auch für die Tiere hier einzustehen.
Bis anhin habe ich es
nur im Ausland gesehen.
Ein Samstag im August.
Jener Tag, auf den die Aktivisten
monatelang hingearbeitet haben,
ist endlich da.
Über 60 Tierschützerinnen
und Tierschützer aus sieben Ländern
sind nach Zürich gereist.
Jeder hat seine Aufgabe, auch Anja S.
Red Team, könnt ihr schnell zuhören?
Ihr habt die Fahrerliste
noch einmal erhalten.
Da seht ihr,
in welchem Auto ihr seid.
Die Bürsten fürs Abschrubben der
Schuhe sind nach Autos geordnet.
Bitte beim rechten Auto zurücklegen.
Der Tag ist da. Mit welchem Gefühl
sind Sie hier?- Etwas nervös.
Man weiss nicht, was einen erwartet.
Entweder Gewalt von der Polizei
oder von den Bauern
oder dass man abgeführt wird.
Ich habe mich damit
im Voraus befasst.
Ich nehme es einfach, wie es kommt.
Haben Sie dieZahnbürste dabei,
falls Sie ins Gefängnis kommen?
Die darf ich wohl nicht mitnehmen.
Es herrscht Stimmung
wie in einem Klassenlager.
Junge Leute, die auf ein Abenteuer
warten. Ausgang ungewiss.
Die Aktivisten schreiben die Telefon-
nummer eines Anwalts auf ihren Arm,
falls sie bei der illegalen Aktion
verhaftet werden.
Ein eigens eingesetzter
Pressesprecher erklärt den Plan.
Wir gehen in einen Schweinestall.
Was wir dort sehen,
werden Sie vor Ort erleben.
Nämlich,
dass es auch bei Label-Firmen ...
Dass es immer um Verletzungen
und natürlich auch Tötungen geht.
Obwohl wir sagen, es sei
ein verhältnismässig guter Stall,
haben wir die Probleme -
das ist systembedingt.
Alles ist straff durchorganisiert.
Jeder weiss, in welchem Auto er sitzt
und welche Aufgabe er
bei der Hofbesetzung übernehmen wird.
Während der Fahrt
beginnen die Aktivisten,
Handschuhe überzustreifen.
Es geht darum, dass niemand
die Tiere im Stall ansteckt.
Anja S. macht alles wohlüberlegt,
auch das Einkaufen.
Sie sucht Gemüse aus,
das aktuell wächst
und möglichst aus der Region stammt.
Das darf auch etwas mehr kosten,
obwohl Anja S.
eher knapp bei Kasse ist.
Seit zweieinhalb Jahren
lebt die Tieraktivistin vegan.
Ihr damaliger Freund
hat ihr die Augen geöffnet.
Ist das ein Regal, an dem Sie
ohne hinzuschauen vorbeigehen?
Ja, für mich ist es ehrlich gesagt
etwas eklig, das anzuschauen.
Ich habe so viele Tiere
in Schlachthöfen gesehen.
Es ist für mich ... Ja ...
Ich gehe rasch daran vorbei.
Ich habe so viel Fleisch gegessen,
dreimal am Tag.
Ich habe sehr viel Käse gegessen -
die ganze Zeit eigentlich -
und Milch getrunken, all die Sachen.
Überdurchschnittlich.
- Absolut.
Ja, ich mochte die Produkte einfach
und sie gehörten zu meinem Leben.
Welches Fleisch
mochten Sie besonders?
Eigentlich alles, ich habe auch
Innereien gegessen. Alles.
Seit sie vegan lebt, hat Anja S.
eine gewisse Intoleranz gegenüber
Andersdenkenden entwickelt.
Sie teilt die Welt ein
in Fleischesser und Veganer.
Setzen Sie sich zu jemandem an den
Tisch, der Fleisch isst?- Nein.
Damit habe ich aufgehört,
seit ich mit Mahnwachen
im Schlachthof angefangen habe.
Ich kann nicht die Tiere schreien
hören und guten Appetit wünschen.
Wenn Sie bei Ihren Eltern
beim Weihnachtsessen sind
und es gibt ein schönes Stück
Fleisch?- Das gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich sage ihnen, dass das
nichts mit ihnen zu tun hat,
aber ich möchte in dem Moment
nicht dabei sein.
Entweder komme ich später dazu
und trinke etwas,
wir essen pflanzlich
oder ich bin halt mal nicht dabei.
* Piepsen *
Wenn Anja S. zu Hause liest,
dient das selten der Entspannung.
Sie bildet sich gerade weiter,
liest ein Praxishandbuch
für linke Aktivisten.
Das soll helfen, wenn es bei
der geplanten Aktion brenzlig wird.
Wie man damit umgeht, auch seelisch,
sollte es zu Repressionen kommen.
Was heisst Repression in Ihrem Fall?
Wenn die Polizei einem mit Dingen,
die nicht stimmen,
Angst einjagen will.
Sie denkt, wir würden es
nicht wissen und darum aufhören.
Oder mit unverhältnismässig
hohen Strafen.
Das ist reineTheorie.
Das erlebten Sie selbst nie?
Nein, aber in Holland sagte man mir
auch Dinge, die nicht stimmen.
Z.B. bei Nichtunterschreiben
eines Dokumentes
würden sie mich
länger in Gewahrsam behalten.
Ich unterschrieb nicht
und war nach 30 Min. draussen.
Der Autokonvoi der Aktivisten
nähert sich dem Bauernhof.
Die Teilnehmer
ziehen ihre Schutzanzüge an.
Hygiene ist oberstes Gebot.
* Pulsierende Musik *
* Rascheln *
Annina, gibst du mir mein Handy?
Dringend.
Danke.
Susi hat angerufen.
Oh Gott, was ist jetzt?
Es rufen noch mehr an, Mann.
Müsst ihr mich alle anrufen?
We talked again to him and ...
He said, that's all they use.
Okay, one second.
Einzelne Aktivisten schlagen Alarm.
Sie sagen, die verteilten
Schutzanzüge seien luftdurchlässig.
One second.
Sie wollen nicht rein.
Wer?
- Das ganze Auto.
Welches?- Jenes mit Susi, Douglas.
Sie gehen nicht rein.
Dann geh ich.
- Wir können nicht zu zweit ...
Ich habe daheim 20 Anzüge,
aber bis die da sind ...
Ich weiss, aber Cheyenne sagt,
sie seien nicht biosecure.
Ich weiss nicht, was tun.
Wir sind in 3 Min. dort.
Wir fahren jetzt einfach ...
Kommt ihr rein oder nicht?
Sie sind von einem Veterinär.
- Ich komme rein.
Es ist zu gefährlich für alle,
die da mit drin sind.
Wir müssen jetzt gehen.
- Ich komme nicht mit rein.
Dann bleibst du draussen.
Ihr wisst, dass ihr alle gefährdet.
Jeder muss selbst entscheiden.
Wenn denn du durchatmen kannst,
sind sie nicht biosecure.
Der Tierarzt trägt sie
auf der Isolationsstation.
Die wissen nicht, was biosecure ist.
Wir müssen jetzt los, sonst
ist die ganze Aktion gefährdet.
Es ist super gefährlich. Ein Freund
von Cheyenne ist an den Krankheiten,
die man kriegen kann, gestorben.
Daran können Menschen sterben,
daran können Tiere sterben.
Ist es das wert?
- Dann bleib du draussen.
Es geht um alle.
Können wir bitte ... Nein. Annina.
Wenn etwas ist,
sind wir Schuld daran.
Auf einem Parkplatz
beraten sich die Aktivisten.
Wie soll es weitergehen,
nachdem sich herausgestellt hat,
dass die Schutzanzüge auch nicht
wasserdicht sind? Einhellige Meinung:
Weitermachen! Es soll eine Aktion
vor dem Stall geben.
Ende der Diskussion, die Zeit drängt.
Könnt ihr ins Auto gehen?
Bitte alle in euer Auto. Okay. Gut.
Okay, gut.
Die Anzüge noch nicht hochziehen,
sie schauen vom Fenster zu. Danke.
Erst jetzt verschickt Anja S.
per SMS die Information,
wo genau sich der Hof befindet.
Es ist verschickt.
Ich hoffe, dass sie es nun erhalten.
Okay.
Die Aktion bleibt
bis zum Schluss streng geheim.
Jetzt nähert sich die Gruppe
dem Bauernhof.
Es gilt ernst.
Die Stallbesetzung beginnt.
Kannst du langsam fahren,
damit die anderen Vans nachkommen?
Maske hoch.- Ja, ist gut.
- Gut. Go.
Go heisst es für Anja S.
nicht das erste Mal.
Sie hat sich an Hofbesetzungen
in Holland, Slowenien,
Grossbritannien und Frankreich
beteiligt.
Dort werden Tiere
oft in riesigen Ställen gehalten.
Ich sass in dem Abteil da hinten,
angekettet am Boden.
Als Symbol dafür, dass Schweine
ihr Leben lang angekettet sind.
Sie haben trotzdem reingeschlagen,
obwohl wir uns
nicht bewegen konnten.
Es war ein Schockmoment,
so ausgeliefert zu sein.
Sie gingen so mit uns um,
obwohl Kameras da waren.
Wir fragten uns, wie sie mit
den Tieren umgehen, ohne Kameras.
Es ist logisch,
dass der Bauer wütend wird,
wenn in seinen Stall
eingedrungen wird.
Wütend ja, aber sie waren bereit,
Leute zu erschiessen,
obwohl diese sich nicht wehrten.
Jemand erlitt durch die Metall-
stangen eine Gehirnerschütterung.
Normal wäre gewesen,
wenn sie die Polizei gerufen hätten
und dann auf diese zu warten,
was hier klar nicht der Fall war.
Einen gewaltigen Medienauflauf gab es
bei einer Stallbesetzung in Holland.
Es war für mich
die erste solche Aktion
und ich war zum ersten Mal
mit den Tieren konfrontiert.
Es war sehr emotional,
den Tieren so nahe zu sein.
Wir waren über 100 Leute
in diesem Betrieb.
Wir waren mehr als 10 Std.
dort drin.
Es war das erste Mal,
dass ich festgenommen wurde.
Nach etwa 1 Std.
waren rund 100 Bauern da.
Sie machten einen Gegenprotest
und verwüsteten unsere Autos.
Wir hatten 50'000 Euro Schaden.
Dagegen wurde bis jetzt
immer noch nichts gemacht.
Zimperlich gehen die Bauern
mit den Besetzern nicht um -
nicht in Holland,
nicht in Frankreich.
Da hinein und hoch fahren.
Und wie wird es in der Schweiz sein?
Alle sind gespannt.
Rauf, rauf, um die Ecke.
Jetzt lässt du uns raus.
Mach die Tür auf, Annina!
Raus.
Nicht auf die Kisten, nur rundherum.
Tipptopp, okay.
Mit einem Spezialleim kleben
die Aktivisten ihre Hände zusammen.
Falls die Polizei
sie abtransportieren will,
wird sie es schwer haben.
* Stimmengewirr *
Der Rest eher vorne,
damit man euch auch sieht.
Als erstes
wird ein Transparent aufgespannt.
Die Nachbarschaft soll wissen:
Dieser Hof ist besetzt.
Doch was heisst überhaupt
Stopp Speziezismus?
(Mann) Speziezismus bedeutet,
dass sich eine Spezies mächtiger
fühlt als eine andere Spezies.
Die Art Mensch hält sich
für wertvoller als ein Schwein,
ein Hund, eine Katze, egal, was.
Diese Überheblichkeit entscheidet,
dass eine andere Spezies gequält,
missbraucht und getötet werden kann.
Selbstverständlich und legal.
Wieso sind Sie
auf den Silo geklettert?
Um Aufmerksamkeit für die Aktion
zu erregen, eindeutig.
Ist Ihnen das gelungen?
- Ja, ich glaube schon.
Gleichzeitig haben Sie sich
in Gefahr begeben.
Das sehe ich nicht so.
Nicht mehr, als die Tiere sich
in Gefahr geben, für unser Essen -
für euer Essen.
Die Stallbesetzung
wird live auf Facebook übertragen.
80'000 schauen zu.
Für die, die sich
jetzt dazu geschaltet haben.
Wir sind in der Schweiz. Das ist die
erste Stallbesetzung in der Schweiz.
Wir bleiben draussen, weil
die Anzüge nicht sicher genug sind
und wir wollen nicht riskieren,
dass davon jemand
einen Schaden trägt.
Wir haben gesagt, dass die Aktion
genauso stattfinden kann,
indem wir uns draussen ansammeln,
sodass wir unsere Forderungen
genauso stellen können.
Unsere Forderungen sind, dass
das Medienteam in den Stall darf
um zu filmen,
wie es drinnen aussieht.
Wir werden auf den Fernsehern,
mitgebracht vom Screenteam, zeigen,
was vorher schon ermittelt wurde.
Anja S. soll sich
um die Technik kümmern.
Dafür muss sie erst
ihre verklebten Hände lösen.
Gut, hast du
so viel Kleber draufgetan.
* Sie ächzt. *
Ich komme gleich.
Ich gehe zum Fernseher
und dann komme ich wieder.
Einige Aktivisten tragen Bildschirme.
Darauf sollen Videos für die
Medienvertreter abgespielt werden.
Doch von der Presse ist keiner da.
Wozu sind die Bildschirme?
- Wir zeigen Aufnahmen vom Betrieb.
Auf einem werden Aufnahmen
von diesem Betrieb laufen.
Die Aufnahmen aus dem Stall
sind kürzlich gemacht worden.
Sie zeigen Medikamente
auf verrotteten Regalen
und Schweine,
die an einem Nabelbruch leiden.
* Grunzen *
Wer hat die Innenaufnahmen
von diesem Stall gemacht?
Das darf ich nicht sagen.
Jemand von den Tierschützern?
- Ja, richtig. Genau.
Um die zu schützen, sagen Sie nicht,
wer es war?- Richtig. Ja, genau.
Die Aktionsollte anders aussehen.
Die erste Stallbesetzung der Schweiz
hat nicht funktioniert.
Ja, wir haben festgestellt, dass
die Anzüge nicht biosecure sind,
d.h. sie sind durchlässig.
Die Problematik der Zoonose
ist uns bekannt.
Pandemien entstehen durch Tiere,
über den Fleischkonsum.
darum sind wir vorsichtig.
Wir bleiben im Aussenbereich und
wenn möglich, vom Bauern bewilligt,
soll eine Person von den Medien
rein können.
In Sachen Schutzanzug war die Aktion
nicht gut vorbereitet.
Doch, sie war perfekt vorbereitet.
Der Mangel wurde zu spät entdeckt.
* Grunzen *
Die Aufnahmen im Innern des Stalls
zeigen kranke Ferkel.
Sie liegen zuckend am Boden
und sterben langsam.
Wenn sie tot sind,
kommen sie in eine Tiefkühltruhe.
Vor genau dieser Tiefkühltruhe
stehen jetzt die Aktivisten.
Sie schauen nach,
ob die Tiere immer noch drin liegen.
Das alles dokumentieren sie
mit der Kamera.
Die Bilder wollen sie
der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich machen.
Mitten in die aufkommende Lethargie
trifft der Bauer auf dem Hof ein.
# Your animals ...
Guten Tag.
Ohne jemanden anzuschauen, geht er an
den Aktivisten vorbei in den Stall.
Er ging wortlos an Ihnen vorbei.
- Das habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Spannende Reaktion. Er wollte evtl.
schauen, ob Leute im Innern sind.
Auf jeden Fall
hat er sich eingeschlossen.
Das habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Gut, schauen wir mal.
Mit dieser Reaktion
haben Sie nicht gerechnet?
Gar nicht. Ich bin gespannt,
was noch geht.
Was tun? Lieder singen und sich
selbst Mut machen und hoffen,
dass der Bauer aus dem Stall kommt
und sich den Aktivisten stellt.
Anja S. auf dem Weg zur Arbeit.
Die 25-Jährige macht eine Ausbildung
zur Pflegerin bei der Spitex.
Ich helfe sehr gern Menschen,
die selbst nicht mehr so gut können.
Es ist auf jeden Fall
ein sehr spannender Job.
Auch anstrengend?
- Definitiv anstrengend.
Man ist körperlich gefordert.
Man muss die Leute heben etc.
Es ist definitiv sehr anstrengend.
Aber das macht nichts,
es ist trotzdem spannend.
Es ist eine halbe Stelle,
die Anja S. bei der Spitex hat.
Ihr Leben ist eine Achterbahn,
vollgespickt mit beruflichen
und privaten Terminen.
Wenn sie sich nicht ums Tierwohl
kümmert, hilft sie Kranken.
Eine Kombination, die zu ihr passt.
Vielen ist es unangenehm, einen
Fremden bei sich zu Hause zu haben.
Einige können sich nicht gut aus-
drücken, man muss einfühlsam sein.
Sie helfen kranken Menschen,
Sie wollen auch Tieren helfen.
Ist helfen wichtig für Sie?
Es ist für alle wichtig,
dass man sich gegenseitig hilft.
Ich finde es schön, wenn ich sehe,
dass ich Menschen oder Tiere
glücklich machen kann.
Helfersyndrom?
Nicht unbedingt.
Und wenn es so ist,
ist es etwas Positives.
Ich bin auch froh, wenn man mir
hilft, wenn ich etwas brauche.
Die Polizei rückt an.
Der Bauer hat sie gerufen.
Für die Aktivisten
ein heikler Moment.
Sie können nicht abschätzen,
ob die Lage eskaliert.
Räumt die Polizei den Bauernhof,
kommen die Besetzer ins Gefängnis?
Eine Aktivistin hat die Aufgabe,
mit den Polizisten zu reden.
Die hören geduldig zu und machen sich
auf die Suche nach dem Bauern,
der sich immer noch
im Stall eingesperrt hat.
* Klopfen *
* Gesang im Hintergrund *
Er wird bei den Schweinen sein.
Trotz der Unruhe auf dem Hof
werden die Tiere immer zutraulicher.
Allmählich gewöhnen sie sich
an die vielen fremden Leute.
Sie lassen sich sogar streicheln.
Was empfinden Sie,
wenn Sie die Schweine streicheln?
Das sind fühlende Lebewesen wie wir.
Wir sperren sie in
ihren eigenen Ausscheidungen ein.
Wir behandeln die Tiere so, als ...
... als ob sie weniger wert sind,
nur weil sie anders aussehen,
weil sie eine andere Nase haben,
andere Ohren,
weil sie
nicht unsere Sprache sprechen.
Eine groteske Situation:
Tierschützer mit Friedensgruss
stehen unbefugt auf einem fremden
Bauernhof, singen Befreiungslieder.
Der Bauer hat sich eingeschlossen,
die Polizei versucht,
die Lage zu erfassen.
Auf einmal
kommt der Bauer aus dem Stall.
Er will mit dem Traktor
nach Hause fahren.
Die Aktivisten verhindern das.
Bitte nicht losfahren!
Entschuldigung,
bitte nicht losfahren!
Entschuldigung!
Hartnäckig suchen sie
einen Dialog mit dem Bauern.
Sie blockieren seine Weiterfahrt.
Doch der Bauer
lässt sich nicht provozieren.
* Motorenlärm *
* Der Motor verstummt. *
Er schaut sie nicht an,
sagt kein Wort.
Als ihm klar wird,
dass er nicht wegfahren kann,
lässt er sich
von der Polizei nach Hause bringen.
Wir möchten mit dem Bauern reden,
unsere Forderungen stellen.
Leider ist er jetzt mit der Polizei
nach Hause gefahren.
Der Bauer hat Sie wie Luft behandelt.
Wie haben Sie das empfunden?
Er war wütend
und natürlich verzweifelt.
Er möchte im Moment
einfach gar nicht sprechen.
Wir haben noch keinen Zugang.
Wie weiter? Die Stimmung
unter den Aktivisten wird schlechter.
Alle sind müde und lustlos.
Auf einmal spricht sich
unter den Aktivisten herum,
dass die Polizei etwas vorhat.
Was wollen sie?
Anja S. weiht die Aktivisten
in den neuen Plan ein.
...  hat er explizit gesagt.
- Ist egal.
Kommt ihr bitte näher zu uns.
Hören uns alle?
Wir können nicht so laut sprechen.
Hier geschieht ... Ich kann nicht
laut reden. Ihr müsst näher kommen.
Wäre das für alle okay?
Es geht los. Die Tür zum Stall
ist immer noch abgeschlossen.
Die Aktivisten suchen einen
anderen Weg, um ins Büro zu gelangen.
Mach das Büro auf.
Die Polizisten überlegen,
wie sie reagieren sollen.
* Sie reden durcheinander. *
Im Moment sind wir das.
Vielleicht gibt es
einen befreundeten Bauern.
Am Ende ....
Dessen sind wir uns bewusst.
Anja S. ist nicht nur
eine unerbittliche Kämpferin.
Sie hat auch eine zarte,
verletzliche, musische Seite.
Mit ihrem Cello
fährt sie in die nächste Stadt,
dort spielt sie im Kammerorchester.
Es ist die erste Probe
seit dem Corona-Lockdown.
Sind Sie eine gute Cellistin?
Ich würde sagen,
ich bin nicht schlecht.
Aber natürlich habe ich mit allem,
was ich nebenbei mache,
nicht mehr
so viel Zeit zum Üben wie früher,
als ich einen Bürojob hatte. Aber
ich spiele immer noch sehr gern.
* Verschiedene Streicherklänge,
Stimmengewirr *
Sind Sie auch sonst im Leben
eine Teamplayerin?
Auf jeden Fall.
Mir ist wichtig, zusammenzuarbeiten.
Mit mehreren Leuten
kann man mehr erreichen.
* Virtuose Orchestermusik *
Es ist still im Schweinestall.
Kein Mensch weit und breit.
Geplant war, dass Aktivisten sich
hier hinsetzen und erst weggehen,
wenn der Bauer mit ihnen verhandelt.
Daraus ist nichts geworden.
Alles hier drin
bleibt gespenstisch ruhig.
Im Büro des Bauern befinden sich
immer noch einige Aktivisten.
Sie haben sich umgesehen
und dabei einiges entdeckt.
Es gibt hier Spritzen.
Einen Spray: No Fight, auch
Antikannibalismus-Spray genannt.
Er wird den Tieren gesprayt,
damit sie sich gegenseitig
nicht beissen.
Sie sind viel zu nahe, als es
ihre natürliche Umgebung vorsieht.
Das führt zu Verhaltensstörungen.
Es ist stickig hier drin,
die Leute sind hungrig und müde.
Sie wollen raus.
Okay, seid ihr ready?
Wir können uns auch die Hand geben,
wenn du willst.
Das Ende der Stallbesetzung
wird für eine Live-Übertragung
im Internet inszeniert.
Ein Teil der Aktivisten
geht ins Freie,
der Rest der Gruppe
empfängt sie draussen mit Gesang.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Gesang *
Dies soll die Abschlussfeier
des Tages sein.
Aber zum Feiern
ist kaum einem zumute.
# So you treat me lesser than ...
# But you are so wrong about me.
Yes you are so wrong about me.
* Schluchzen *
# ... the difference
* Gitarre, Gesang *
Es war wie immer:
Man weiss nicht, was passiert.
Es kam ganz anders heraus, als es
sich irgendjemand vorgestellt hat.
Ich hatte schon so viele Szenarien.
D a s  hätte ich nie erwartet.
Sie hatten Tränen in den Augen. Es
hat Sie emotional sehr mitgenommen?
Ja, es war schon emotional. Wenn
so ein Tag zu Ende geht, dann ...
Dazu die Schreie der Tiere
im Hintergrund.
Wir wissen, wieso wir
da stehen. Das ist emotional.
Es war ein Tag, der Fleischesser
zum Umdenken anregen sollte.
Aber die Tierschützer
blieben unter sich.
Die Öffentlichkeit
hat kaum Notiz davon genommen.
Die Aktivisten
geben deswegen nicht auf.
Sie wollen
bald einen neuen Stall besetzen.
Anja S. wird bestimmt dabei sein.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020